ウダエット！！！ぱっと見なんか壺っぽいですねえ;v:
周りを気にせず全力で歌って歌うまになる
大きな声を出してもへっちゃら
70%減ボリュームダウン
ほおおおおおすごい！
ウダエッドってやつ
まさにこの人の通りなんですけど
これか！この中で声を出すとボリュームがすごいダウンしてしまうらしいです
うぉおほんとだ、おぉお、おぉぉぉおおおお
えぇぇぇ？！うぉぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ（すぅぅぅぅぅ）
うぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ↑↑↑↑↑
今はこれ外してなったら多分カメラ壊れてます
はじめしゃちょーです☆
なるほどなっ、音を70％もダウンさせるのか、すごいな、というわけでこれを使うと人に迷惑をかけず、大きな音を出せる！というもどでございます！
このチューブを通すと自分の声を聴きながらもできるというやつか
これで自分の声がすごいクリアに聞こえるらしいです...
はいこんな感じですね...あぁ～あぁ～～あぁ～～、おぉぉ↑おぉぉーーぉ↑↑↑
これすごいです、自分の声が自分の耳にだけにきれいに聞こえます
これ結構大声でしゃべってるんで、外すとすごい声がでかいんですけどぉ！
これつけてると結構小さく聞こえると思いませんこれぇ
えっすごいなぁーおい
といことで今日は！！
これぇ70％音をカットできるということなのでぇ
これを使えばもっといろんなものの音とかカットできるじゃないんだと僕は思いましてぇ
ちょっと音がでかそうなものを今回買ってきました
普段音がでかすぎて聞こえないような音もひょっとしたらこれを通せば聞こえるんじゃないかと思いましてぇ
極端にうるさいものを何個か買ってきたんでぇ、実際に迷惑レベルで音が大きいものを
ko・no・na・ka・de☆鳴らしてみてぇ
どれくらい音が小さくなるのか、確かめてみようと思います
BGM（ででぇーんっででっでんででででぇーんでっでででっで）
これでぇレベル１ですからね
ふえ（ピィッ!!)
なぁこれくじょうレベルでうるさいぞ
ふえ（ピィッ!!)（2回目）
ふえ（ピィィィィィィ!ピッピ!ピッ!!!)    ふえ君（ふぅ）
みなさん今の音を覚えてください、この音を果たしてウダエッドの中で聞くと
どれぐらいの音になるのかちょっと聞いてみてください
行きます。。。行きます！！
ＢＧＭ（デッンデッデデデッン）
ふえ（プィィィィィィィィィィィィィィィイィプゥゥゥゥゥゥ）
うあああああああああぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ↑↑　　うるっせえええええええええええええええええ（泣き）
笛をここまで音を閉じ込めるれるとは
なかなかですよ、ふえは何とかおさえれた！！
ＢＧＭ（デッデデデッデデデンデンデッデン）
なんか僕ちょっと経験上こういう小さい奴ほど
うるさいんですよぉ多分
一回鳴らしてみます
サッカーの応援的な奴（プゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥ）
．．．．．．．．．．．．．．．．．
うるさぁ
これもウダエッドを使うとどれだけ小さくなるのでしょうか
あ、待って入らねえや
え無理だよだってこれはいらないもん
失・格☆
ＢＧＭ（デッデデデッデデデンデンデンデン）
防犯ブザーも結構音があれぇ(・・?
ど，ど、どうなってんだこれぇ？
外れないよぉ
え？え？え？これこおここおわかんないよ
いやとれてーやそこは
もう音なったりしないかなぁ
防犯ブザー（ピヨピヨピヨピヨ♂）
あぁーーなったなったなった！！！！
この音皆さん覚えておいて下さい
防犯ブザー（ピヨピヨピヨピヨ）
これが果たしてウダエッドのどれだえ小さくなるのか
やってみましょう
防犯ブザー（ピヨピヨピヨピヨ）防犯ブザー（はぁはぁ）
おおおおおおおおおおおおお↑おおおおお↑おおおおおおおおおおおお↑
うるさぁぁぁい(´;ω;｀)
ＢＧＭ（デッデデデッデデデデデデッデデデデデデデデデデデデッデッデデデデッデデデッデデデデデデッデデデデデ）
うるさいよおおおおおおお！
ＢＧＭ（デッデデデッデデデッデッデデンンデ）
クラッカーもなかなかうるさと思うんですけど
ま、こんな感じの音ですね
クラッカー（パっ！）
ですがこれをウダエッドの中でやるとお
行きます。。。
クラッカー（パっ）
おお！おおおおおおお↑↑すごいすごいすごおおおい！！すごおお
全然音がなんなかった！！！
ねえあんたすごいねぇなんでも音が消せるの。。
クラッカーがきれいな音も聞こえるのかもしれない
クラッカー（パっ）
はじめ（あっあっあぁあああああ）
ＢＧＭ（デッデデデッデデデッデッデデンンデ）
この爆竹の音を止めれればほんとにすごいと思います
爆竹（バッバババンバッババンバンババ ンバン）
いかに音を小さめれるかが今回の...（かちっ）
うぁ、この途中で止まるのほんとにヤダ
爆竹（ドンッドどんっ どんどんどっ）
ＢＧＭ（ﾃｰﾃﾞｰﾃｰﾃﾞｰﾃｰﾃﾞｰﾃｰﾃﾞｰﾃｰｰｰﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾞｰ♪ﾃﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾞテデデﾃﾞｰﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃデ↑デ↓デ↑デ↓デ↑デデデデン♪デデデデデデデデッデデデデン）